I gotta say you're quite an amazing
surprise to see in this film
I heard you squeeze it in between John
wick three production um yeah was was
really fun to get the invitation it was
a big fan of alleys and they had a nice
kind of like play yourself in some kind
of alternate universe and yeah so it was
fun to go from John wick to a version of
me
right but with such wonderful artists
guys how you congratulations I mean what
does it mean to you to know that all
these fans showed up at the box office
for John Wood 3 it's really special the
way the film was embraced you know it's
something that you you hope for but you
can really even hope I mean it was it's
pretty extraordinary and and just really
so special and
thank you right exactly well you're
about to give them again with the John
wait for EM you guys wasted no time
making that announcement yeah we'll see
what happens but it's really cool to at
least have the opportunity you know and
the only way we get that opportunity is
that people enjoy what we're doing so it
was cool for the studio to support that
and say okay well you know what next is
people want to speed3 I don't you've
been asked that a lot but yeah I
wouldn't you wouldn't you be down the
path
well you know that we would love to see
you in Sandra Bullock back together so
what I a real quick villain Ted save
save the music what do you want fans to
know about this next installment well
Bill and Ted are a little older they
were supposed to unite the world with
their music and it hasn't happened so
they're still trying to write the song
but now it's not just unite the world
that saved the universe you know Bill
and Ted that's we call Bill and Ted to
save I guess a key ah no saving the
universe so thank you at least the movie
[Music]